let's talk about the World Cup
[Applause]
32 men's teams are coming here to Qatar
to compete for that famous golden trophy
we can expect a month of incredible
football with moments of glory and
despair all the drama that defines every
World Cup we want to see the shop we
want to see the surprise and many will
want to see Ronaldo and Messi two of
football's biggest stars in what's
probably their last chance to claim the
sports top prize neither of them is
wanted so I think this will be the the
main story with the with the World Cup
this year now this is also a World Cup
that comes with a lot of controversy off
a pitch we looked at that in our last
episode but for this video we're going
to focus on the sport and if you don't
usually follow football here's what you
need to know
foreign
the tournament starts on November 20th
there will be 64 matches over a month
the first two weeks are the group stage
where the teams are divided into eight
groups of four and everyone plays
everyone within their group you get
three points for a win one for a draw
and zero if you lose the two teams in
each group with the most points qualify
for the next round now at every World
Cup people like to talk about what's
called the group of death where
especially strong teams are lumped
together this year some people think
that's group E with Germany Spain Costa
Rica and Japan others reckon it's Group
B which has England USA Iran and Wales
when you look at the FIFA rankings
that is the hardest group because there
isn't any team that's outside the top
20. after the group stage come The
Knockout rounds if you lose here you go
home
starts with 16 teams eight go through to
the quarterfinals four make it to the
semis then it's just the two left for
the final on December 18th we obviously
don't know who's going to get through to
the Knockouts yet but we do know the
matchups in the group stage and here are
five worth looking out for first up the
heavyweights Germany against Spain those
are world champions in 2010 and 2014
going head to head so I think that will
be the standout game from the group
state next up the old rivals England
versus the USA there's plenty of healthy
animosity between these fans and some
especially on the American side like to
take it back 300 years part of the B for
the English fans is that football was
invented in England whereas in the
States soccer wasn't considered a major
sport until relatively recently but
England have never beaten the US in a
world cup so there's a very famous
occasion in 1950 when England were
beaten by the USA one mil it was such a
shock that almost in the days before the
internet and communication one newspaper
thought well they couldn't have lost one
nil so they actually put it down as 10-1
to England it was that big a shot okay
so our next pick is Ghana Uruguay this
match will be about settling old scores
for Ghana at least because of what
happened the last time they met back in
2010.
Uruguay's Striker Luis Suarez prevented
a goal by Ghana with an Infamous
handball probably the most infamous
after maradona's hand of God back in
1986
Suarez was sent off but Uruguay ended up
winning on penalties I can guarantee
there was another guy name who has
forgotten about that match where they
were and the Heartbreak they went
through they're going to be up for
Revenge now sometimes Sport and politics
can be hard to separate and that's what
we're dealing with at the Iran USA match
the relationship between the U.S and
Iranian governments is as strained as
ever with issues like Iran's nuclear
program U.S sanctions on Iran and the
Iranian government's hard-line response
to recent protests there
the question is how might that play out
on the pitch or in the stands Iran
versus the USA I guess is the
politically Stand Out game they have
played each other 24 years ago in France
98 and it was actually Iran's first ever
win at the World Cup even though it's 24
years later it's still under a
politically charged atmosphere between
the two countries of course it will be
an interesting match because of the
political context but
it it's again football in the end and I
don't think it affects it will be
affected too much by that now our last
pick is Qatar versus Ecuador it's the
opening game and will be the big debut
for Qatar at the home team
now the host nation usually gets a big
Boost from home fans but Qatar are
definitely underdogs they're the lowest
ranked team in their group and have
never qualified for a World Cup before
but they're in because the hosts always
get a spot and Qatar will want to show
how far they've come as a footballing
nation it's something they've been
focused on ever since they won the World
Cup bit in 2010. they've come through
their acts with the same coach since the
ages of under 16 under 19. so they know
each other very well the coach knows his
players very well Felix Sanchez say came
from Barcelona so he was at the famous
LA macia Academy so there is a bit of a
Barcelona influence going on here and
considering how good Barcelona are and
their Academy is you know one of the
best if not the best in the world you
know I think they're ready and they're
primed and I think they might surprise a
few people okay so those are some of the
group matches to look out for something
else to keep an eye on though is how the
timing of this World Cup might affect
the player's performance because there
are different views on that
normally World Cups start in June but
this one was moved to November to avoid
the worst of qatar's desert heat it
means the tournament Falls during the
season for Europe's top leagues which
most of the world's best footballers
play in they've had to fit in more
matches within the first two or three
months so lots of high profile players
have been injured and obviously with
with a summer World Cup usually you do
have you have a little bit of a space
for those injured players to recover
before competing in the world cup but
right now being mid-season it will be a
difficult my view is that it will be
better for the flow and they will be
more tuned to playing every week I don't
think it's going to be a problem
whatever the effect of this new schedule
we're going to see some serious talent
and here are some big names to watch out
for
there's Francis Killian mbappe who plays
for Paris saint-german and is known for
his super fast dribbling Sun kyung Min
is the South Korean Captain he's one of
the Best Wingers in the world and plays
for Tottenham in the English Premier
League and of course we've got Brazil's
star forward Neymar de Silva Santos
he's the one that has the burden of over
220 million people on his shoulder like
he did back in 2014 and like he did back
in 2018 as well and then there are some
big players who might be playing their
last ever World Cup and that includes
two football legends Portugal's
Cristiano Ronaldo and Lionel Messi of
Argentina between them they have
dominated the headlines over the last 10
15 years both incredible players are
both so fit and so committed they're
both coming into their fifth World Cup
but this is their last chance because
message 35 Ronaldo's 37. you're not
going to be playing when you're 39 and
41. okay so which team looks likely to
win this thing well there are some
obvious favorites Europe's got strong
contenders like Germany Spain Belgium
and England and of course there are the
defending champions of France but World
Cup history suggests it's hard to hold
on to your title usually the Champions
the following tournament don't do
terribly well and then three of the last
four tournaments they've gone out of the
group stage so there's some sort of
Hangover there seems to be something
that goes slightly wrong with defending
champions the last four World Cups have
been one by European nations I think if
anyone is going to break that European
dominance is going to have to be either
Argentina or Brazil Argentina are
usually strong and they seem to be in
good form this year they're the current
champions of the Copa America plus
they've got messy on that mission to win
a World Cup title before he retires and
what about Brazil well they've won the
most World Cups ever and are going into
this tournament as the top ranked team
when you actually look at their squad
you just think oh my word they don't
have a weakness Brazil haven't won the
World Cup for a little while now you
know so it's 20 years
um so they must they're going to be
itching to do that stick with Al Jazeera
during the World Cup I'll be out and
about here in Qatar posting videos about
everything happening off the pitch so
make sure to follow us on social media
for all the updates
[Music]